the last time palestinians voted in a
legislative election
facebook and twitter were months away
from being launched globally
the year was 2006. they couldn't have
known then
they would spend the next 15 years with
a divided government
and no chance to elect a new one
15 years without an election and we're
facing a miserable situation
as a mother i wish it will happen and
things change for the better
an election for the palestinian
legislative council is scheduled
for may but already there is widespread
expectation palestinians won't be
rushing to a polling station
these elections are only for renewing
the legitimacy of palestinian leaders
and to continue to rely on foreign aid
but in the long term
it will not serve the palestinian people
israel has yet to approve voting in east
jerusalem
fatah has splintered and both fatah and
hamas are worried about losses in their
own bases
due to disaffected voters
professor mohamer abu seda says recent
polls show
hamas would be lucky to get 25 percent
of the vote in gaza
but it might be able to get a bigger
share in the west bank
where people are fed up with the
palestinian authority
but maybe after the elections we might
see
a new or different kind of coalitions
but that will probably be
against the will of the international
community which is still classifying
hamas
as a terrorist organization and also
israel which doesn't want to see hamas
in any form of a palestinian government
so a united or a unified government
between hamas and fatah is unlikely
hamas spokesman fawzi barhoom says the
organization
is pushing for the election to take
place as scheduled
and that palestinians are primarily
frustrated by the israeli occupation
not their leaders
the world and the international
community should help us choose our
leader
and to take our rights back we should be
living in a good situation like all the
human beings in this region
a generation of palestinians has come of
age
living with a divided government and no
way of changing it at the ballot box
the question people are asking is will
this year mark
a long overdue change natasha ghanim
al-jazeera gaza